Speaker 1: This is a very interesting. Jon
Voight, the actor father of Angelina Jolie,
he has been a right wing guy for a while now,
pro-Trump guy, kind of a MAGA hero. Jon Voight
has gone off script as far as the MAGA people
are concerned after the Uvalde, Texas shooting
and is now saying, oh, we need screening and we
need testing for people who are going to have
firearms. This is absolutely fascinating
around election 2020. Jon Voight
said he thought that he and Donald Trump were
in our greatest fight since the Civil War.
He has you know, he used to be kind
of like a moderate. He supported JFK
and whatever. But he's gone completely off the
rails more recently. Conspiratorial stuff. Talking
about Democratic propaganda with subliminal
messages that Obama was a godlike figure that he
would be make America socialists like Jon Voight
went hard right and pro-Trump and all of a sudden
in the last few days. Two days ago, right after
the Uvalde, Texas, shooting, he put out what I
would argue are the sanest words he would. He
has spoken in years, going 180 from what the
MAGA people believe. Take a look at this. Sure.
Speaker 4: That we will never see this horror
again in this lifetime. We must identify
every individual for their credentials,
for their mental capacity to bear arms.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 4: There should be proper qualifications
for gun ownership and proper testing. One should
only own a gun if they're qualified and
schooled. I stand with all I stand for
freedom of each soul's truths. I stand for God's
truth. I stand for one to be condemned. For evil.
Speaker 1: Doings. Now, he still can't get away
from this weird, conspiratorial, religious speak.
He can't even get away from that in this
segment. But he's saying, we need testing,
we need evaluation, we need licensing,
we need training. This is already more
than Republicans are willing to concede.
Speaker 4: And that they must pay a price.
May God watch over all and bring comfort
for this loss which may never heal.
For each child was so precious a gift and God
will call on Jesus to pray for these families.
Loved you.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So he's still
a very wacky guy. I'm not going to deny that. But
this is not going to put him in the good graces
of the Trumpists. That's for sure. But everything
Jon Voight is saying makes perfect sense. How do
you buy? Over the weekend, I spent time looking
at how do you get firearms in Switzerland? People
love to talk about Switzerland and guns. How do
you get guns in a number of different countries?
Look at Japan as an example. In order to get a
gun in Japan, you have to take a firearms class
and pass a written exam. That's only done
three times a year. So it's not like, Oh,
I want a gun this weekend. I'll just go and
do the thing this weekend. That's number one.
You've got to get a doctor's note saying you're
mentally fit and have no history of drug abuse.
You have to apply for a permit to take live
firing training, and that can take a month
to get. You have to meet with police
and explain why do you need a gun?
You have to pass a review of your criminal
history, gun possession, record employment,
involvement with organized crime, personal debt,
relationships with friends, family and neighbors.
You have to apply for a gun powder permit.
You then have to take a one day training class
and pass a firing test. You've got to get a
certificate from a gun dealer describing the
firearm that you're looking to get to, to buy.
Then you've got to if you want a hunting gun,
apply for a hunting license. You have to buy a
gun safe and an ammunition looper locker that
meets safety regulations. You then have to let
police come in and inspect that. You actually
have the proper storage setup. You pass one more
additional background review, and at that point,
you are given a permit with which you can go
and get your gun. You can still get a gun,
but there is serious scrutiny of the
people that are looking to do it.
Many of those elements are part of what I've laid
out. And I have to tell you all my liberal gun
owning friends are fine with everything on my
list. And why wouldn't they be? Because their
goal isn't more guns in more places. Their goal is
we have a Second Amendment. Different people might
have different reasons for wanting to have
a firearm, which, by the way, might include
that so many right wingers have them. And
I'm willing to go through a difficult process
because it will make me feel better that only
people who really safely can have firearms have
them. It's and listen, as far as Jon Voight goes,
it's glad to see him talk a little sense. It's
been about a decade of him not making any sense.
Unfortunately, sadly, I don't know that any of
those things I mentioned last week or that Jon
Voight mentioned in his in his clip are going to
become a reality anytime soon. But we are seeing
some cracks with a few Republicans saying, okay,
now it's too far. Now we finally have to do
something. We'll soon see whether they do.